you should go to bed when your partner does
if you want a happy marriage or relationship
you should always remember that
going to bed together is one of the most important parts of the day
yes I know you're probably like ugh
but I'm not tired when they are,
or they snore,
or I need to get X
y and Z done before bed
so many couples don't go to bed together
instead one will stay up to watch TV or get work done
often you'll find that couples that don't go to bed together
don't spend a lot of quality time together
they’re losing their connection or spark
which ends up leading to an unhappy marriage or relationship,
or even worse, divorce.
please make an effort to go to bed together,
discuss your day together, cuddle,
embrace each other with warmth!
simply just spend the last moments of each day together if you want a happy
long lasting marriage/relationship